e aí galera que aceite o canal tudo com
você e eu estou ótimo obrigado a
perguntar a todo lugar que eu vou da
terra qualquer lugar qualquer lugar do
lugar todo todo todo todo todo o carro
vai terminá-lo santana jorge mateus
gusttavo lima seja no táxi no
restaurante no meio da rua e aí no
estudo boca e lançou douglas voltando
avaí no meio da rua
i na mente e qual não é dado é retardar
certeza tem problema vamos aqui é mais
algumas limitações já que não cansa de
passar vergonha né gente bruno barreto
tem aqui um saque agressivo a red bull e
marreta que o pessoal que canta ninguém
tem duas maneiras mais ou menos assim
como se fosse um cd ralado mas só quem
falou foi a voz do cantor ea voz dele só
quando fosse em forma de arrotos máscara
vai cantar acontece isto
[Música]
eu quero só acaba só acaba só acaba com
os pés sua voz foi ontem quando o time
paraguaio foi normal
na dúvida não é cuidado a gente esquece
você cai do cavalo
assim achando é bom preparar com um
pouco de mal de parkinson e troca
é cuidado e esquecidos e cais do cavaco
e você achando é a prefeita eu dia eu te
esqueço pra gaveta
e um dia eu disse zhu tac a pena agora
só cabe um pouco mais normal do que
aquele cara do local o envio de polícia
aqui ó adiante tem que prender aqueles
querem agora com fernando
a dúvida do ego o extrato que eu diz que
se você cai do cavalo
viajando o é aproveitar que um dia eu te
esqueço na gaveta
eu diria eu te esqueço na gaveta
é
[Música]
[Aplausos]
lançam sinto garra também fazia amor
minha emoção fechar a taxa de mulheres é
daquelas idéias que tudo venha por aí na
tv tupi onde acham que estou fazendo
algo de mais de minas o tipo foi no
caldeirão do huck em várias cidades
cidades de taquari e da refer namorada
da tarde boina tito uma sede cosmi
avançando nos concelhos onde ficou a
este mundo a mulher na rua poderosas e
teme-se vinho onde se viam os caras da
voz mais bonita que tudo foi ficando
como se tivesse levado desde que o terno
toma o normal seria sim um bem que é com
ela é bom te ver
mas condeno todo fica assim como é bom
te falta quem hoje tu tá de volta pra
mostrar que é capa
hoje tu tá de volta pra mostrar que é
capaz que é capaz
a amm e matheus e kauan também nota
fiscal é um estilo bem parecido com
jorge mateus só com a voz um pouco mais
gripada e muito muito muito mais
sorridente é que dá aquele efeito de voz
de matheus e kauan ao invés de uma testa
volta à pista de pouso ou menina festa
grande no meu caminho também é
pequenininha se tornando tamo junto mas
a itf dois pilotos acabam nem pra cima
pode fechar pra cima
foi na casa de janinha
você querendo ver
eu olhava e eu quero céu eu não
não quem não vai curar o que ama ladeira
nossa bota em seu casaco rosa
[Música]
[Aplausos]
e assim eu disse aí quero ver você aqui
é zero né
se você vai gostar de alguma dessas
limitações é só clicar aqui no youtube
gostei que você me ajuda demais o que
mais vai com esse vídeo mas me ajuda mas
eu fico feliz e mais o grupo toca no
facebook ou porque esse vídeo e vídeo
novo revela e você clicar em curtir nos
comentários no facebook e marcou amigo
seu que gosta de alguns desses artistas
que emitem aqui e aí mais gente vai ver
são muito bons e estão sendo recordista
de likes no facebook obrigado pelo
esforço você está gravando mais que você
se inscreve o canal nunca perdeu um
vídeo novo vai sair muita coisa boa e
esse ano vai muita coisa boa do 22 no
bairro muita coisa boa série no canal é
nóis muito obrigado como aqui em baixo
qualquer tipo que você quer que o limite
que eu vou tentar não valeu caiu